all right the holidays are here and the  trees are up this is Kylie Jenner's  amazing tree done up and go and if I  have to do a tree it will be definitely  gold absolutely celebrities are just  like us they love a good Christmas tree  obviously some of them are a little over  the top summer a little more down to  earth we're gonna look at him  this is Maksim Chmerkovskiy decorating  his tree on natural he's naked oh I  didn't even notice him back there all  right J Lo and a watch tree beautiful  victory the star on the top and also  their kids decorating here's Kelly Ripa  and a Mark Consuelos tree a very classic  looking tree lots of ornaments mm-hmm  and queer eyes Bobby Burke he goes for  them well the very minimalist look tree  needs a little water a little it's cute  I kind of like it I mean with the  background the picture it works it goes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]